good morning John A couple of years ago
I found out a Cool Secret that there's a
warehouse in my hometown right behind me
right now that used to be part of a
lumber mill and there's still lumber
mill stuff going on right now it smells
like wood here but now in that building
they make the soap for like organic
luxury Beauty Brands brands that you
have heard of but that I cannot say the
names of because this is like a secret
but I can tell you why they do this
because it's hard to make great soap so
what happens is companies work with
suppliers and if you want to get amazing
soap that feels great and smells
delicious and is 100 organic there's a
good chance that you're gonna end up
working with botany it is fascinating to
me that there could very easily be two
fancy soaps right next to each other on
the grocery store shelf with two totally
different brands and looks and feels
marketed to different groups of people
and you might also have one at a
farmer's market and they are all made in
this building now botani's Client List
is extremely secret companies want the
people buying their products to imagine
that they had like a perfect image of a
soap in their mind and then it just
started to exist somehow but like this
is the the way that it actually works
and the fact that I know people who work
at a company who make a high quality
luxury bath stuff for some of the most
respected companies in the beauty
industry is super cool and the only
thing cooler is that I can just work
with them which is what we have been
doing they know so much about soap about
which oils are best to clean while still
moisturizing how to Source all the best
ingredients and we've been talking to
them for over a year now and we are
creating our own brand called Sun Basin
soap which just like all of the other
unnamable people who work with this
company is extremely nice high quality
velvety soap but unlike them the sun
Basin soap Club you guessed it donates
all of its profit to charity and because
we don't have to do a bunch of fancy
marketing around it the final product is
actually cheaper than the brands that
work with botany you could go now you
can order a sample pack with all five of
our current fragrance options each a
different experience with different
exfoliants and different fragrances
everybody in the office has a different
favorite but I think that mine is
probably Navigator which just for like a
fresh smell it's one word description is
clean mean but one of the best parts of
the sun Basin experience has got to be
our product descriptions right here's
here's Navigators waves cradling a
weathered boat a globe of stars
pointillism as a glittering map steady
eyes searching Open Fields with Horizons
obscured by humid Haze a clasping hand
firmly pulling forward inexorable motion
determined cessation and no an
artificial intelligence did not write
that you could subscribe for every month
every two months or every three months
and for either one two three or six bars
with more bulk buying resulting in
cheaper individual bars because bulk
ordering lowers our costs FYI on average
a well-drained bar of soap will last a
person who showers once a day about a
month domestic shipping is four dollars
no matter how much you order and of
course you can cancel your subscription
at any time I love this soap I've been
using it for years and it is made among
the Mountains of Montana by people who
care about their impact on the world and
I'm excited to share it with more people
so you can check out Sun Basin Soap by
going to good dot store John I'll see
you on Tuesday